points soit par le privilège de
l'informateur et ce qui est au coeur de
cette décision de la cour d'appel d'une
cinquantaine de pages pourquoi c'est si
important et pourquoi c'est au coeur de
céder si c'est un principe extrêmement
important on part du principe que au
canada et heureusement la justice allait
public surtout en matière criminelle les
procès sont publiques les gens peuvent
aller au palais de justice voire des
procès les jugements sans son rapporté
les médias peuvent rapporter ce qui se
passe dans une salle est fondamental
c'est à la base de la démocratie pour
s'assurer que la justice est
effectivement bien rendu parce que la
justice et pour le public du nord il
faut la confiance du public mais il ya
des renseignements qui doivent demeurer
confidentiels pour des impératifs de
sécurité de vie privée il ya ce qu'on
appelle les privilèges et un des
privilèges les plus importants souci
important quel secret professionnel de
l'avocat qu'on connaît tous c'est ce
qu'on appelle la protection de
l'indicateur protection des informations
qui tendent à révéler l'identité d'un
informateur pour que la police puisse
mener des enquêtes elle a besoin
d'information il ya des gens qui ont de
l'information à donner sur des crimes
révélé des crimes donner des détails
mais qui veulent pas témoigné à la cour
alors veulent avoir l'assurance que si
je collabore avec la police on ne va pas
révéler mon identité ou des informations
qui pourraient identifier par peur de
représailles et c'est un privilège qu'on
dit absolue là ça veut dire que la
justice les juges les tribunaux sont
obligés de protéger les informations qui
révèle l'identité de l'informateur mais
certains pourraient saisir la date du
procès le nom du juge lieu du procès est
ce que réellement ça peut permettre
d'identifier la personne est ce que
certaines informations n'est pas tout de
même maîtrise quasi peut être dévoilée
st menacer sa sécurité c'est une
question de réputation légitime l'on va
rentrer dans les particularités de cette
affaire-là ce qui a été reproché au
départ c'est que le procès s'est tenu
entièrement dans le secret y a pas de
numéro de dossier est pas d'inscription
dans les ordinateurs du palais de
justice quand même pas dans un palais de
justice que ça lui les seules personnes
qui savaient qu'il ya eu ce procès sont
ceux qui y ont participé à la cour
d'appel dit que ça va trop loin sur des
renseignements particuliers comme le nom
du juge trick judiciaire etc le nom des
avocats
c'est un aspect qui a été soigneusement
étudiée par la cour d'appel qui conclut
que dans ce cas très particulier
particulier ici qui est quand même assez
unique ce sont des renseignements qui
pourrait tendre à révéler l'identité
d'un informateur alors renseignement qui
à première vue peut avoir d'un anodin
pour le public une information et
signifiante pour ceux qui sont concernés
sont abusés par exemple des complices ça
pourrait révéler l'identité est-ce qui
est pas tout de même risque de dérive
ultérieurement un précédent qui pourrait
mener davantage d'opacité ce qui
pourrait mener à une perte de confiance
envers le système de justice encore une
fois c'est une préoccupation qui
légitime mais je ne m'en inquiète pas la
justice ali transparente hockey au
québec et au canada on est dans l'ultra
exceptionnelle pour ne pas dire unique
d'une part et la cour d'appel dénoncé la
façon de faire la première fois on n'y a
pas nécessairement une mauvaise foi on
voulait bien faire les protagonistes la
première fois était animée par
l'intention de protéger ce qui doit être
protégé c'est à dire l'identité de
l'informateur mais on était la procédure
la manière de faire était exagéré c'est
très particulier c'est on est dans
l'unique ici et la cour d'appel qui le
tribunal suprême pour le québec dénonce
cette façon de faire alors je suis pas
inquiet pour le futur tribunal suprême
pour le québec mais certains disent que
ce précédent cour suprême oui le croyez
vous alors c'est à suivre c'est à voir
je désire y avait plusieurs recours
important ici avait plusieurs médias il
y avait le procureur général du québec
le ministre justice avait exprimé des
préoccupations quand ça a été révélée à
quelques mois et aussi la juge de la
cour du québec qui voulait avoir un
accès limité au dossier me demander
accès se demande a été refusée ils ont
un droit d'appel est ce qu'ils vont
faire appel à la cour suprême on verra
lyon 60 jours merci beaucoup mais très
jazzy je vous en prie et au revoir